when xena first showed up as a character
on hercules the legendary journeys there
was no way
anyone could have predicted that
audiences would still be talking about
her decades later
how did this spin-off become such a
phenomenon well here's everything you
need to know about xena warrior princess
the character of xena made her first
appearance on hercules the legendary
journeys as a villainous warlord
out to kill kevin sorbo's hercules her
arc was supposed to end with her death
instead the character proved so popular
that she earned a spin-off
in the hercules episode the warrior
princess xena's fighting prowess is on
full display though her outfit is not
yet the iconic one
worn in her series cena's goal is to
seduce michael hurst's eoless hercules
best bud in order to get close enough to
herc to kill him
in her next episode the gauntlet she
finally gets close to hercules but in
the final episode of her trilogy
unchained heart xena reforms herself and
goes off to make amends for her
treacherous past
this wasn't lucy lawless's first time on
the show believe it or not
she'd already appeared in a smaller role
as lyla the wife of a centaur in the
season one episode as darkness falls
before that she'd popped up as lycia in
the 1994 pilot movie hercules and the
amazon women
when the actress originally cast a xena
vanessa angel became ill
lalis got the part the rest is
television history
like hercules its parent show xena
warrior princess is steeped in greek
mythology
though it's never said outright it
certainly implied that xena might be a
demi-goddess
her mother cyrene shares a name with a
legendary water nymph
moreover it's hinted in the furies that
xena's father is ares the greek god of
war
considering the often flirtatious nature
of aries and xena's interactions that
would be
um not great by current standards but
totally in line with greek myth
xena being a demi-goddess would
certainly explain her beyond human
fighting feats
granted cutting through dozens of
soldiers with apparent ease may merely
mean xena is super agile and has a
skilled fighting style
however xena's ability to hold her own
against the various gods and goddesses
she encounters and
frequently defeats puts her on par with
the fully powered hercules
some godly parentage would make that a
whole lot more plausible
xena warrior princess began with a lot
of promise having been spun off from a
popular action fantasy show which was
already solidly established hercules
managed to head off competition from
star trek deep space nine
and even topped baywatch even still it
didn't take long for xena to start
surpassing it
xena eventually joined hercules in
beating out baywatch in 1996
besting hercules was something xena kept
doing hitting a ratings high of 7.8
the week of february 23rd 1997.
eventually xena even managed to wrestle
the top syndication spot away from the
ratings behemoth that was star trek the
next generation
as reported in the daily universe
executive producer rob tapper told tv
guide
our initial goal was to bump off
baywatch as the number two show this
is something i never expected to
accomplish like many shows xena warrior
princess
had its ups and downs in the ratings but
it continued to maintain its popularity
over hercules
not only did it last longer its series
finale also scored higher ratings
lucy lawless met rob tapert an executive
producer on hercules and xena
after she was cast the two were wed in
1998 but lawless and tapper did not date
right away
it took a couple of years before they
were even officially an item
still lawless told people magazine
tapart is the finest man i've ever known
the pair have two sons julius and judah
the couple continues to collaborate on
projects lalas had roles in two of
tapper's other television shows
spartacus blood and sand and ash vs evil
dead
xena warrior princess features plenty of
then small time actors who have gone on
to do big things
if you had to narrow the list down to
the two biggest actors to guest on xena
warrior princess you would most
certainly end up with bruce campbell who
played atolicus and
carl urban who played several roles on
the show including julius caesar
campbell who is internationally renowned
as ash williams of the evil dead
franchise had a role in one of the most
important scenes in the show's history
atolicus kisses gabrielle while he's
possessed by zena
campbell spoke fondly of his time as
italicus on the xena 25 podcast and
expressed the belief that the show had
more of an impact than hercules because
of its complexity
he expressed delight at seeing fans
dressed as italicus so many years later
saying anything that has resonance
decades later means it was worth doing
carl urban has gone far since his early
days on xena he's beloved for his work
on the boys and major franchises
including the marvel cinematic universe
the lord of the rings and star trek
urban told woosh.com in 1998
that he enjoyed working on xena and
hercules due to the show's environments
saying you get on set there and we have
fun it's like a family
when xena began airing fan conventions
were still fairly niche
so when creation entertainment which has
been hosting fan conventions since 1971
held a small event in 1997 dedicated to
xena and hercules
it was a big deal when it was promoted
to a full-scale touring convention in
1999
it was an even bigger deal guests at the
first event included lucy lawless kevin
sorbo and renee o'connor
the first two events proved so popular
that creation had to expand the
convention to larger venues to
accommodate fan demand
we do make a good team as the los
angeles times reported in 1998 hercules
fans were scarce compared to these z
nights a fan created term for xena
lovers still a good time was had by all
among those at these events was a then
unknown ryan gosling there to promote
young hercules and carl urban covering
the beatles
creation alone could not satisfy the z
knight's enthusiasm
several other xena conventions and
events popped up across the united
states everywhere from las vegas to new
york city
xena and gabrielle's subtextual love
story is a big part of why xena became
such a sensation
though nothing was ever made irrefutably
explicit that didn't stop the lgbtq plus
community from embracing the show
wholeheartedly
even still as pacific standard notes
some fans were disappointed that the
xena and gabrielle characters were never
openly queer
still it can't be denied that xena
blazed a major trail
though the show doesn't make xena and
gabrielle's romantic relationship
canonical
the current comic book series has no
such restraints there
xena and gabrielle are portrayed as
being in a long-term relationship
you are the most dear thing to me in all
the world
lalas herself describes xena as gay as
early as 2003
even deeming the pair to be essentially
married for her part lawless has always
expressed delight at being considered a
gay icon
she told out magazine in 2003 i've
always been grateful to lesbian fans for
picking up on my show first i feel they
made it hip
rene o'connor might be best known as
gabrielle but in fact she's a jill of
all trades she directed two episodes of
xena 1999's deja vu all over again and
2001's dangerous prey
since her days on the show came to an
end she's tapped into other talents
including producing
stage acting teaching podcasting and art
most prominently o'connor has her own
company roc productions
which provides video production services
and has produced films including 2017's
watch the sky and 2016's the usual
o'connor has quite a bit of experience
performing on stage
taking on such meaty roles as lady
macbeth she also teaches classes on
shakespeare's monologues and on sanford
meisner's acting techniques
teaching has had to take a back seat
recently however as o'connor has focused
on producing a podcast on the culture of
1960s austin
on top of all of this o'connor is also a
painter
even with all that under her belt
o'connor has said she'd play gabrielle
again if the show was ever revived
in 2017 she told fox news i would love
to revisit these characters again
obviously it would be a completely
different experience but i think it
would be really interesting if that came
up
and if we could actually play the same
characters
zena's costume is a big part of what
makes her instantly recognizable it's so
iconic in fact that it's displayed in
two museums
one costume was donated in 2001 to the
museum of new zealand to papa tongarua
while lalas donated the other to the
smithsonian institution's national
museum of american history
xena's legendary look is detailed and
intricate
incorporating materials like leather
mother of pearl and brass
barbara dara the costumes designer says
she took inspiration from art nouveau
among other movements and eras one of
the more interesting details of the
costume is the size of the boots
does xena have huge feet not exactly the
boots actually contain
running shoes to allow lawless more
comfort and freedom of movement
hopefully this made up for the boning in
the corset which was tight enough to
make lawless uncomfortable
though she's proficient with just about
everything xena's favorite weapon is her
chakram
she gains multiple chakram throughout
the series including the balanced
chakram which can break into two halves
to be used
separately though xena's magical weapon
is fictional the
chakram is actually a real south asian
weapon it's said to be wielded by vishnu
one of hinduism's major deities
in entertainment weekly's oral herstory
of the show rob tapper recalled director
doug leffler coming up with the
signature weapon rather casually
saying leffler said hey this is the
object she should have when we find her
in hercules
this round-throwing object that shocked
them this should be the warrior
princess's weapon
although the show's chakram were mostly
harmless props often made of rubber to
be more easily tossed around
one metal chakram prop was actually
dangerous its inlaid stones were made of
abalone which emits a toxic dust when
ground
real world chakra may not fly as
magically as they do on the show but
they sure can still kill a person if
they're made of abalone and assembled in
an area without proper ventilation
a whole lot of care went into the
development of zena's character from
what she wears to who she loves to her
unforgettable battle cry
as lucy lawless told people tv her
future husband rob tappert decided that
xena needed a quote
signature call like tarzan right around
then lala saw a funeral on tv where arab
women
were ululating a type of trilling howl
used to express strong emotion
in zina's case it's used as a clear and
intimidating war cry
lalas couldn't quite mimic what she saw
on tv so she tweaked it into her own
thing
thus xena gained her very own tarzan
style howl the illusion lawless heard
that fateful day has a name
it's called the zagruda and can be heard
throughout the middle east
it isn't restricted to funerals and can
be heard during happy occasions
including weddings and graduations
it was even used by pop star shakira who
introduced much of the world to zagruda
during the 2020 super bowl halftime show
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one